we want to start tonight talking about
1493 one of the first talks we had here
with Matt Ridley talking about ideas
having sex and about the great benefits
of trade and what that does when ideas
mingle and this is really about sort of
plants having sex across yes and it has
just amazing impacts I mean that's
stunning this thing called the Columbian
Exchange which is what happened after
Columbus discovered the new world and
could you just start out by telling us
what the Columbian Exchange was and why
it matters that I know that's a whole
book but just thank you there's a
slightly odd thing where I want to talk
to the man here but then I turn my back
on you so I what I'll do is I'll talk to
John and periodically Fame you know this
kind of thing in this sort of robotic
way anyway the premise of the book which
will save you $30 is that if you step
back and think about the reason that
Columbus is important is that as you
probably know 10 20 200 million years
ago or so the world consisted of a
single giant landmass scientists called
Pangaea geological forces broke it up
forever separating the continents and
forever separating the ecosystems on
those continents and what Columbus did
was in effect recreate Pangaea all of a
sudden his ships and the ships that
followed brought over huge numbers of
creatures from over there to over here
and returned vessels brought huge
numbers of creatures from over here to
over there and the result this
ecological mixing was a convulsion in
the history of life and the biggest
event since in the history of life since
the death of the dinosaurs and the
argument I make in the book is both of
this is interesting in and of itself but
it also played a big role in human
history as well
now what were some of the things for
instance just I'm just talking about a
few of the events for instance just the
the Industrial Revolution might not have
happened the way it did without this
right yeah for if you want to have an
industrial revolution turns out you need
three raw materials in addition to the
human knowledge involved and one is you
need steel which basically comes from
iron irons all over the place you need
fossil fuels
fossil fuels are all over the place and
the third thing you need is rubber
you need something to prevent you know
these metal pieces from flying apart
when you have a steam engine you need
belts you need
tires me I don't know if any of you have
ridden the old kind of bicycles that
didn't have tires but it's not an
experience that any man would enjoy
let's put it that way and so it turns
out that rubber these elastomers are not
really widely distributed and in fact
the very best ones are found in two
species of trees that are only in Brazil
javea brazilians is in Castilla elastica
and so in the 19th century as lots of
nations in Europe and elsewhere
industrialized there is a great scramble
for the Amazon to take over the Amazon
and to corner the supply of rubber which
led to all kinds of havoc but as you
said that the Industrial Revolution
wouldn't really have happened the way it
did without this right you just you need
the rubber - oh for instance if you want
to you know to transmit the motion of an
engine to something else you need belts
and belts are made out of rubber if you
want to have wheels you've effectively
need some kind of tire and those are
made out of out of out of rubber if you
want to have steam engines you need
gaskets I mean I think we know from the
Challenger what happens when a gasket
doesn't work right and so all of this is
you need some kind of rubber now there
is synthetic rubber but it wasn't
invented until later in the 20th century
and it is it turns out it's not nearly
as good to this day as as natural rubber
from trees and so all the rubber in
airplane tires for example you know
anything that really needs stress is
made it is goes in to see all of
airplane tires are made out of hundred
percent natural rubber the rate the
sidewalls and your radial tire is a
hundred percent natural rubber the
serpentine belt in all of your cars 100%
natural rubber and on and on and on it's
about 45 percent of the world market now
there's some disconcerting news in the
book for locavores
and now you yourself like to eat local
food you say but but you guys you're a
fraud though I'm a fraud yeah I mean I
mean it's it's my hobby and like I live
in Amherst Massachusetts which is kind
of like the Berkley of the East Coast
right you guys know about it yeah and so
we have like our own you know farmers
markets and we're very earnest and I'm
extremely earnest as well I'd like to
just say I fit right in and so we have
our garden I
like my garden and it gives me this
feeling of home and you know I'm capable
of really being boring on the subject
but the point is it's completely bogus
and the reason is that there's
absolutely nothing in my garden or I
think in any garden in New England that
originated within two or three thousand
miles of New England I mean I'll grow
tomatoes which come from Mexico I grow
lettuce which you know came from Europe
I grew up garlic which came from the
Middle East you know you just go on and
on and on and there's absolutely nothing
in my it's this cosmopolitan exotic
modern object and that pretending to be
this sort of traditional homey artifact
but it's in fact as space-age as
anything you can imagine now we've
talked a lot here about in previous
discussions about the sort of you know
trade in general and yeah you know and
they're people who promote more trade
globalization there's a lot of free
traders in this room but now you talk in
the book a lot about both the benefits
now the obvious benefits are that Italy
has tomatoes and that and and the China
got peppers you know the you know from
this Colombian exchange once once all
that started happening but but you say
that there also that sometimes the free
trade advocates underestimate the costs
of globalization well there's there's
two things I think that are going on I
talked about in the book the first is if
you think about the free trade that's
described in economics textbooks you
know it's always between willing buyers
and willing sellers and in fact states
use trade all the time to agree you know
for self-aggrandizement for the purposes
of power and then you know that what
happens then is much less free economic
exchange as a means of gaining things
for this or that political entity and
the the examples of that throughout
history are just enormous starting with
the fact that the Chautauqua for a long
time is that China for example had this
as you learn in the textbooks had this
trade ban and what it really meant was
that the government sought to monopolize
trade a hundred percent for the for the
court and in control all the benefits
for itself so that any kind of trade
with China wasn't you know in any way
like the kind of stuff that we talked
about free trade and of course this was
the largest and most sophisticated
country in the world for centuries upon
centuries and the
second thing is that often people aren't
aware of everything that they're trading
so that the people who brought the
potato to euro Bay we have no record of
it they had no idea that they were
bringing something that would transform
European agriculture for the good
similar the same people who brought
potato blight to Europe which had
enormous and negative impact killed a
couple million people in the famine of
1845 also had no idea with what they're
doing
so the accounts in free trade basically
free trades this enormous force for good
but it's also enormously complicated to
to fully quantify how much of that good
is is there it's basically the argument
from these two reasons
well now in looking back at the history
of this I mean in terms of the
environmental downside of there's an
upside to it upside down step you talk
about malaria travel Indiana travelled
across the ocean and all these organisms
and Indians you know smallpox of course
you know coming in with the Columbian
Exchange in kind of a Holocaust here
in the Americas among the Native
Americans you know I mean looking over
all at the at the environmental impact
which kind of countries have managed it
better I mean I mean what kind of
governments of man it's sort of the
environmental you know controlling the
environmental damages but better these
in it's interesting I mean you know you
okay they're okay it's it's interesting
you know this is something I've been
thinking about as I look at this and you
know all of these free trade brings
these unexpected trade of all sorts
brings these unexpected environmental
consequences and the nations that do in
general a better job of managing at our
democratic nations the nations that do
the worst are places like China where
the legacy of the Columbian Exchange is
has been catastrophic and the the way
that the Chinese are dealing with is
kind of mind-boggling I could go on and
on and on it was one of the I went to
China eight nine times for this book and
at the end I thought wow this country's
screwed up I mean how did that happen
how did what ways did it screw up and
okay well what they did is here's the
bait you know when I went to junior high
school we we didn't learn any geography
I don't know what we learned I don't
think
learned anything and it was like a
progressive school you know and they
they they told us about our feelings and
so forth it means like that you know
when people have these denounce these
progressive schools there's like a
caricature and we say couldn't be that
bad actually
that was my school and so town junior
high school was just we didn't learn
anything and so I didn't actually look
at a map until I was like 25 and if you
look at the map at shining it so
constantly it struck me fresh you know
I've looked damn you can see all the
stuff there you know and if you look at
the map of China about half of China is
this desert right there's it and there's
no lakes there there's no big lake so we
don't have a Great Lakes I don't have
anything like that there's all these two
major rivers the Yangtze and the Yellow
River and the rest of it is the sort of
dry hills and there's only two like flat
areas where you would want to grow
anything there's the North China Plain
and then there's a little one in the
middle of the country where all our rice
and so you have China with what 20% of
the world's population something like
that 7% of the world's above ground
fresh water and the crop they want to
grow in what everybody wants to eat has
to be grown in swimming pools I mean
it's completely insane you know and this
is like a one-sentence summary of
Chinese history right yeah you know this
incredibly due to the fact that people
are geniuses they're able to sort of
pull this off and so they're actually
able to give people rice and and so
forth but it's like they're barely doing
this considering it's impossible sort of
amazing they did it at all and then
about 1,600 big dramatic change when
these crops come over from the Americas
and the two big ones are sweet potatoes
in maize which is what people call corn
outside the United States and they come
in at that point almost all of China's
population the han population is
concentrated in the east and suddenly
get these crops you can grow in dry
lands that are the first sort of crops
we can get a lot of calories from dry
land and if you go into the western
desert it's unbelievable they're growing
corn stuff that it's like farming a
beach it's unbelievable and so what the
so what the Ming Dynasty does and then
the Ching dynasty does and then the Mao
dynasty because it goes right up in the
20th century is they take basically
whole villages and they shove them out
west and they say you know cut down the
trees on these
slopes and plants sweet potatoes and in
corn and by the way kick out the
indigenous people and so just like we're
doing they're doing there's this
parallel movement you know go west young
Chinamen and kick out the indigenous
people kill them if possible and plant
your crops and since the Chinese have
never done this before they make
beginners mistakes and so they start
they what they're told to do is Terrace
these things and so they again it's
right out of the 20th century it's
amazing and so they take all these dry
hills and they cut these terraces and
there's hundreds of miles of them in
northwest China and in southwest China
it's a kind of wedding cake effect and
it turns out that terraces actually
require sort of sophisticated
engineering and knowledge to build them
because otherwise if they're made out of
dirt they fall down when it rains and so
occasionally even in these dry areas or
rains and if you stay in the villages
which I did a few times when it rains
everybody's up at four o'clock in the
morning and you hear is they get out
their hand tools and are trying to patch
up these these things and of course you
can imagine how well it works and so
after these things are about a hundred
years old they just fall right down into
the steep hills and so pretty soon China
as a result of this has the world's
worst erosion problem is it's amazing it
looks like our bad lands only it and
people we if you go on the tourist buses
they'll say look at these time ancient
you know terraces that our people have
been farming for thousands of years it's
complete nonsense they're like 100 years
old and so they cause all this erosion
and then it turns out
but turns out that there's this really
interesting bit of physics and rivers
you know while the rivers because
eventually what happens to the dirt you
know the sediment goes into a little
creek which goes into a slightly larger
river which goes into a slightly larger
River which ends up in the Yellow River
or the Yangtze River and while they're
there in these steep hills the water is
turbulent and so all the dirt stays in
the in the water but as soon as they get
to these flat areas you know North China
Plain and these areas where people are
trying to grow something like rice the
river you know flattens out and it slows
down and the stuff precipitates down to
the bottom and there's a lot of it and
so when it precipitates on the bottom
the bottom gets high you know builds up
and pretty soon you have this bizarre
phenomena bottom of the river is higher
than the surrounding land and they're
places in China where the the Yellow
River is like 30 feet above the
surrounding land and you don't have to
be like a genius PhD in physics to
realize that having a giant river 30
feet in the air isn't really stable
right and so the answer is floods what
happens in massive floods from this and
so I went to the Chinese state
meteorological Bureau and you have this
tremendous bureaucracy in China forever
and one of the things that happened is
there's all these counties and they had
to have a County report every every year
and give it to the central government
and so the Chinese meteorological bureau
had gone through all these County
reports for 600 years and made these
flood maps of China and you can just see
them starting the late 18th century and
just getting huge huge huge floods and I
was looking at it's like nothing in our
history so I said to one of the
meteorologists you know how should I
explain this to Americans it's so weird
look what's happening and he said just
tell them we had a Katrina per month for
a hundred years so so so they you know
what happens is the the dynasty just
rings its hands there's no way for local
people there's tons of evidence locally
we will exactly what's going on but
there's no way for them to communicate
you know to the state the state didn't
didn't care see how all these flood
refugees going around flood refugees
from the southeast caused something
called the Taiping rebellion that kills
20 million people it's just a mess and
it ends up that you know at the end of
the 19th century small groups of your
pians are able to push into this giant
country that used to be the world's most
sophisticated and push them around and
it has an awful lot to do with this
idiot legacy of environmental disaster
which goes right into the 20th century
and so now the mountainous T as I sort
of nastily like to think of it is saying
oh wow we have to do something and so
what do they do they go to these
villages these same farmers who've been
pushed around all this time and they say
after you finish your harvest you get to
work for us for free and what you get to
do is plant trees because we want to and
we're going to take part of your land
and you're going to devote it to trees
and so they of course don't like this
and so what they figured out is you have
to go out into the hills and you dig
these pits which is a lot of work and
then you plant the trees and it's a lot
of better if you don't have to dig the
pits year after year so they they
cultivate northern pines and other trees
and I'm not going to do well and so they
deliberately plant you know the same
trees and the same pits year after year
after year and I met these guys they
said oh yeah I've been doing six seven
years it just gets everything done
faster you know I don't have to do this
I get to sleep and of course they do I
mean there there's no recompense for
them and so when you probably now and
then we'll read accounts what these
fantastic efforts are being made in
China to reforest the country and you
know reverse these environmental
degradation and you should take it with
like the biggest grain of salt you have
available now speaking of environmental
degradation you recently appeared with
Jared Diamond and the who is the
geographer who's written bestsellers
about these great environmental you know
collapses and and now as you've told me
that most of these things he writes
about in fact you know serious
geographers have serious qualms about it
that way he gave it I was telling you he
gave a talk and I was I
I like the geographers when I was a kid
I always wanted to be an explorer and
geographers are as close as you can get
and so there I like them because they
they just want to find out what happened
Joey wait and so they so I was sitting
with a table of them including the sort
of famous guy named William Dennison
who's one of the great geographers of
the the Amazon and Jared Diamond gives a
talk and it's about environmental
determinism is that a phrase you guys
know and basically the environment
dictates what's possible for us and so
he and so when you supersede these
environmental limits the nature's gonna
come and crush you down
yeah like Easter Island and the
Greenland exactly so there's these own
collapses and two geographers this is
like fingernails on the blackboard and
the reason is well there's that there
you know in addition to it being wrong
has this idea has a terrible history in
that in the beginning of the 20th
century Geographic textbooks and you can
you can read them you know would say
stuff like oh people in Latin America
and Asia will never amount to anything
because you can't think in a hot climate
and you know which is just ridiculous
and racist and all the other stuff so
they're kind of embarrassed to buy it
and so they really don't want to stay
clear of those kind of arguments in
addition they don't actually believe
that it's impossible to sink in a hot
climate and that that sort of stuff and
so diamond gets out there he gives us
full throated defensive this idea and
it's this modern form and this guy denna
Ben who is this famous geographer turned
to me at the end he said well a long
time since I heard that
I mean but I mean diamonds idea is that
that there are these environmental
limits and that we really and that all
these societies have collapsed because
they've exceeded them and the moral is
of course we are now about to see towers
and less before always put on our
cardigan sweaters and turn down turn
turned down the thermostat and eat lower
on the food chain and reduce the human
footprint and all that stuff and I just
it it's sort of hard to know where to
start actually but in one of the things
that I do wish is that I mean I'm not an
economics genius buddy to take economics
101 and you know the human activity the
impact of human activities is not on the
environment it's not like like if I go
to the Opera you know I walk up a town
to the Opera that is registered as GDP
and it's registered just as much as if I
you know make my money out of I don't
know poisoning something and they
obviously have dramatically different
impacts yet you can read this whole
thing this whole literature about how
GDP equals you know the growth
necessarily equals destruction and this
is just the start of of that kind of
what seems to me economic illiteracy
plus you've you find yourself in these
arguments like as I had you know
discussions with him he said oh you can
tell that there is no way that the
people in Australia were ever going you
know the original inhabitants were ever
going to develop boats because there are
no islands to see from there so why
would they go and so they're there
perpetually doomed to never to have
trade and then I thought well
Australia's big so they didn't if you're
sitting there it doesn't look like an
island when you're it doesn't look like
a little tiny desert island when you're
there right it looks like this continent
and the people in western South America
I mean it looks it doesn't look that
different and there aren't a lot of
islands there but there's huge amounts
of shipping up and down there forth in
pre-columbian America but his suggestion
is that you know that anyway goes on
also the Chinese never became had sea
power because there are no
in China he wrote which was kind of
astonishing if to you if you ever been
to a Chinese port but also it's kind of
a sign because China hits like a zillion
boats and has always had a zillion boats
right so he goes anyway sorry to hammer
on them no but I remember Julian Simon
the economist was kind of my mentor
talking about you know Paul air look and
the other sort of ecological determinist
and he liked to quote I think it was
Henry George the the economist saying
that both humans and Jayhawks eat
chickens but the more Jay Hawks the
fewer chickens the more humans the more
chickens you know that humans do
different things right so we're a weird
species yeah yeah and and you know there
is I mean in fairness to these guys are
coming you know from the idea that one
of Darwin's great lessons is that human
beings are you know animals like other
other animals great truths of biology
but and so they basically say well like
zebra mussels you know my understanding
is the zebra mussels come they
proliferate across Lake Erie they eat
everything that a zebra mussel can eat
in Lake Erie and then they all die right
cuz you know zebra mussels don't say
let's invent farming but and so they say
well human beings are like zebra mussels
or what have you
we're you know they're fundamentally
identical and the argument from a social
science perspective or an economics
perspective is well we're not you know
ultimately and I think that's the basic
difference is that if you come from this
biological perspective you have this
idea you know between you john tierney
and me and a Paramecium you know it's
just a we're sort of bigger but not even
different yeah I'm will Paul Ararat the
great ecological tutor and doom ser he's
a butterfly specialist right and he used
that knowledge to basically you know
forecast it's less attractive right
except now we want to take some
questions from the audience here or
well I've got the mic I tell us
something about methane hydrates and how
they're going to solve the world's fuel
problem and address the problem of of
geopolitical disruption I have a I made
them I was in cautiously told him I have
a piece coming out in the Atlantic
Monthly about methane hydrates do you
know what those are yeah yeah so methane
hydrate the idea is said the sediment
sediment comes off the land and goes
into the ocean at the continental
margins and then it trickles down to the
bottom and there it's eaten by
microorganisms that generate methane
just like if you walk past a swamp you
know there's these bubbles of methane
that pop up and so they generate the
same thing but the water down there you
know at a thousand feet or so is cold
and there's a lot of pressure and under
those circumstances what happens is a
methane and water react together and
create this kind of it looks like ice
and it there's and it sits there in the
sediment and there's just incredible
amounts of it that have built up over
over over the millennia there's some
estimates that there's twice as much
methane hydrate is there as all other
fossil fuels combined that's and so
Japan which is really really tired of
giving all of its money to the Middle
East has been working on mining these
things and turns out that you can
essentially use a variant of fracking
technology it's called horizontal
drilling these things are these
horizontal belts and you can take a mine
go down there and then turn sideways
kinda like an anime drawing or something
instead of you know a roadrunner drawing
it wriggles through this really and you
can warm up by shooting steam in there
the methane then escapes and they just
ran their first commercial test of this
thing they got four million cubic feet
of methane from the nan Chi trough which
is you know not far from Nagoya just a
couple weeks ago and the US has been
investigating it since 1982 and the the
argument I make in the the article is
that we really there is just a lot of
this stuff and even if mo
it is inaccessible a a small fraction of
a big number is still a big number and
what will mean for us is less important
because we have through fracking and you
know other sources of natural gas but
for a nation like China India Japan
Australia New Zealand much of Africa all
which have methane hydrate deposits
would mean the chance to not have to
shovel money towards the Middle East and
other OPEC nations and those nations you
know we're not talking tomorrow but the
day after tomorrow face the kind of
defunding and they're there obviously
you need geopolitical ramifications
we know the oils in the Middle East but
where are the these are all along the
continental margins of most of the world
yeah pretty much
I mean it's easier to say where they
aren't then where they are and so
there's tons of them for instance off of
West Africa the big positives in our in
the Arctic for the Unites States are in
the Arctic around Alaska and then
there's an area vote they think it's
about 175,000 I think I think anyway
there's a sort of a California sized
area or something like that in the Gulf
of Mexico and there's the argument is
that there's there's roughly 3500 4000
oil and gas wells in the Gulf of Mexico
now many of them are drilling through
methane hydrate to get to the
conventional deposits makes a lot of
sense to adapt them to fracking
technology as the conventional deposits
are exhausted I want to ask you about
China although you mentioned fracking so
but in particular by China we've been
reading a lot about this terrible air
pollution in Beijing it sort of stains
the Chinese image more broadly of course
for the last several years about China
we've been subjected to the idea that
just as Japan in the late 1980s was
supposed to dominate the world within
about 15 years we've been reading the
same thing about China that it's at
least China is much bigger than Japan in
terms of population so maybe it has a
better chance than Japan had but what
you're too
reactions first of all to the air
pollution problem in China which is when
you read about it in The Times
it sounds appalling and implications
they can't do anything about it
and what's your broader view about
whether China is going to be you know
the the dominant country of the world in
about 20-25 years the well China's
obviously gonna be in a very important
country it's a fifth of the world's
population so I mean it should be right
so you know in I guess I have a little
different feeling about this and I mean
from my perspective one of the great
things the great things that's happened
in all of our lifetimes is that hundreds
of millions of people in Asia have been
lifted out of in the last 3040 years
lifted out of destitution into you know
something much better
same thing for Latin America and parts
of Africa it's just you know the
enormous change when I went to high
school was it 40 percent of the world
was malnourished or something like that
and now it's like 8 percent I don't I'm
those exactly the right numbers but
they're roughly the right numbers so
it's a it's a huge huge change and a
huge great thing in China's case it's
complicated by the fact that you know
there's been enormous environmental
damage and the sort of normal mechanisms
by which people could say hey you know
you're screwing up my water hey you're
screwing up my air in a non democratic
society that people just don't have the
ability to to protest in in that way and
so you get really strange things I was
telling John lunch I went to this city
in northwest China close to the edge of
the Mongolia and Inner Mongolia it's
right by the border there and there's
the the Great Wall goes through there
and I thought oh great I'll get to see
if you go to see it by Beijing it's it's
all reconstructed bikes I could see what
it really looks like you know and so
with my friend we walked over there
and the idea the Great Wall is it was
all crumbly but still you could see it
is that there are towers every third of
a mile or so and they could people could
signal you know you could wave a flag
and say the Mongols are coming or
whatever and so I thought oh cool let's
climb up you know one of these towers
and so he climbed up the tower and the
air was so dirty we couldn't see
the towers up there you know and I
thought wow it's weird I picked up my
glasses and there's like black specks
all over them black carbon from from
this and you realize then when you take
a shower you know even though he just
walked a mile or something like that it
was like so we're like these extras in a
coal-mining movie you know that water
pouring off of us so it's really
unbelievably dirty and from my
perspective China switching to natural
gas is like a great thing we need the
there's the black carbon we know is
everything we find out about it is is
worse and so that that's these are huge
issues for China but the real limitation
I think for them is water
they've been mind-bogglingly careless
about water and I'm sure this group here
would have something to say about why
that was the lack of privatization and
so forth basically the central
government controls all the water and
people just do really nutty things about
it I could go on and on and on about
things that I saw with my own eyes that
tell you that I just don't know what
they're gonna do you know people were
there they're already starting to do
things like the city of Tianjin has
spent about ten billion dollars rewiring
replumb the whole central city to become
to have grey water you know used in it
and then the world I think it's the
world's largest desalination complexes
in North East China now of course
they're fighting with each other because
the people in the desalination wanted to
sell their stuff to Tianjin so you they
have really serious problems to to
overcome and I think it's gonna slow
down their growth a lot so this is a
question for both of you and it's about
sort of the disconnect between economics
the environment energy and evolution
they all begin with thee right all right
but but but it goes back to the question
of limits of growth and and in Darwin
was very influenced by Malthus
and-and-and free market
and and so the the you know there's this
paradigm problem at some point entropy
energy and epistemology so that so I
want you both to speculate John you can
go first but but but the disconnect
between environmentalists are probably
more evolutionary Darwinian blend by any
economist don't care crap about Malthus
well I mean it's surprising how many
economists still actually either
subscribe to some of this idea about
resource scarcity they you know whenever
there's a commodity thing but there is
this basic thing where ecologist look at
the world and see these these finite
ecosystems they study animals and
animals do reach limits and and one
species wins the other doesn't but
humans are just fundamentally different
and and I think if you look at the
history of you know the me back in the
the classic text when the 19th century
was I was by William Jevons is that
called the coal question and he looked
at this thing and he was very scientific
and said you know we have a finite
amount of coal and Great Britain's and
the you know greatness depends on coal
and we're gonna run out there was just
he looked at the graph was very simple
and he actually he was little bit
different than today's environmentalists
and that he said you know we should
think should we save it for the future
or should we just indulge it all and
have one last great you know party here
and in the also recognized that it was
this coal that made our society great
that we couldn't have had all this
culture and wealth of the last century
and it was kind of a reasonable thing to
think then but but now the you know we
look around and we have more energy now
and I mean just thanks to nuclear energy
I mean we have enough energy in the
hydrocarbons and everything to last for
millions of years one if you have energy
I don't there's nothing to stop you I
think and we can grow enough food to
feed you know population many times the
size we have so I don't think there are
meaningful limits to growth and when you
look at the problems that seem so
catastrophic today about global warming
I mean just first just 30 years ago when
there was you know concerns in the 60s
that we'd all starved to death it wasn't
of food we'd freeze the
things now that maybe the ocean would be
you know several feet higher or maybe
the air be warmer these could be
problems but they're not they're not you
know deals to Breakers at all well it's
wrong for humans and we're gonna move to
Mars well these things that's that's I
mean I just think with energy and food
was enough energy and food that I think
there's plenty of water I mean you could
recycle it right I mean there's all this
water on the ocean and you just have to
price water the big problem is it is in
priced most places if you price it
people will conserve it and but I'll let
you can disagree I think that the issue
is that you know our species does these
amazing things we're not very good at
governing ourselves and government is
like this you know it's interesting to
read about and learn about the
government's in the in the past and you
know there's this enormous rate of
improvement in almost every other sort
of material quality of human life and
then you look at government and and I
realize I'm preaching good but religion
government they're sort of like this
usually and so I feel like you know
every time I feel really optimistic then
I look at something the government is
done and I want to shoot myself and I
should not exaggerate the one of the
things that really struck me when I was
in one of the times I went to China I
went they for the in 2011 I think it was
there was a World's Fair in Shanghai and
so the Chinese government decided to
clean up Shanghai and they took several
thousand factories that have been to the
edge of Shanghai on the unbelievably
aptly named Phu river and and said
essentially you go further up the the
Yangtze you know you locate relocate
yourself a couple hundred miles out of
the site of the tourists and so with the
collusion of local governments they just
kick people out and put in these the
these these factories and just
heedlessly drain the water tables so
much that some of these cities in a
space
decade had in space of a couple years
rather had actually the the the cities
had sunk you know by by almost a meter
and it was just in the buildings were
all tottery and and so forth and they
they drain the the accuracy was because
the there is just absolutely no kind of
effective governments nobody was you
know nobody wasn't getting them to pay
anything and so they just took it all
and figure well I moved to the next
place everything it was free and the
there was tremendous amount of bribery
going on and so I met these guys who
were in response to public outcry is the
government had put in these guys on
bicycles who were supposed to go around
looking for illegal water hookups and
they told me that the system and working
great that in the first six months they
had found six thousand illegal water
hookups and in this Chungking and had
and they had find these factories as
much as $500 a piece so the system does
work after all one of the interesting
plot lines in fortune 93 I thought was
the history of currencies on a global
level and currencies are very much
popular topic these days so one of the
things in particular that was
interesting was China failed both with a
fiat and a hard money currency yeah you
want to talk a little bit about that and
about the Colombian change and silver
moving around all these over in effects
China is to place it and I mean the
tremendous ease amazing stuff that the
poured out of that country and one of
the things he invented way ahead of
everybody else was was currency paper
paper money you know dates back at least
to about 900 and you know first paper
currency doesn't appear in in Europe
until the early 17th century I think it
is and so they have this and what
immediately happens is the invent
hyperinflation you know what happens is
the the idea of paper money as as you
know is great because the problem with
the other kind where you have lumps of
silver around is that you know or gold
or whatever you think is is is as
valuable is that
sometimes the metal becomes more
valuable than the currency and so people
melt it down and that in addition you
have this problem that most the time you
don't you don't control your own money
supply because people are out there
mining gold and silver and an example of
that was that the the Cowrie shell was a
terrific currency in Africa and the
Indian Ocean for centuries until
Europeans found a huge source of it
outside of the sort of purview of them
and brought in you know dump truck loads
of cowrie shells and this currency that
existed for generation upon generation
was blown apart in a couple in a couple
decades and so you know all of these
systems are unsatisfactory so then you
say well you don't want to have these
these things the ideal thing you want is
something as valueless as just a token
value does have value in itself that's
money but then governments realize that
all they have to do to pay for stuff is
print little paper squares and give them
to people and then they will you know
get all this valuable stuff in return
and so then you invent hyperinflation so
that the what would ended up happening
in China is first the this system broke
down and then they started having coins
but they didn't have enough silver for
for the coins they also had this
peculiar rule only to a government would
do this that when the emperor came in
only coins stamped with his face were
valuable all the old coins no longer
were valuable and so when the Emperor
died we started getting sick what you
did is frantically tried to spend all
your money before it became became
valueless and then there wouldn't be
enough around so the new emperor would
would sort of stall on printing it if
people would have these sort of semi
legal coins and they would and they
would they would vary from place to
place to place there's a complete mess
and eventually they just gave up and
said we're gonna trade lumps of raw
silver and so people would carry around
these little ink 'its of silver and when
you wanted to buy something you would
they had all these sort of freelance
silver wares you'd go to the silverware
and you'd shave off your little bits of
silver and then he was he would say okay
this is you know one ounce of silver and
it's worth whatever it is that you're
buying and then meanwhile both buyer and
seller try to bribe the silversmith
to to say to say oh this is actually not
as pure as you say it is or and that
sort of thing so it's a complete
disaster and all this made the country
very vulnerable when Spain 1545
discovered the world's largest silver
strike in southern bolivia by the way
that's the most important thing that
happened in the Americas for a long time
in southern Bolivia they discovered this
thing it's like a mountain of pure
silver called Potosi and this vast wash
of silver came out of out of there a big
chunk of it ended up in in China where
it became the currency just the quick
question you touched earlier on how bad
we are governing ourselves but you also
mentioned that democracies might be
better than not so I'm wondering if
instead of trying to make more countries
into democracies if the easier problem
to solve is to figure out correct
pricing for different issues such as
water or other constrained resources get
your views on it I you know the question
is could we somehow do away with
government and just to have the correct
prices for resources and has anybody
ever actually managed to do this in
history what weight but with no cover
there is no government in Iceland or
Ireland yeah okay and how long did they
last right
well I thought it I sudden had the
oldest Parliament it seems like most the
time there people fall to the to having
a government and I guess my feeling
about tomorrow you know Winston
Churchill's famous remark about
democracy which is the worst of all
possible political systems that's it for
all the others and that seems to me the
case you know what is it William F
Buckley wrote two cheers for the for the
market I sort of filled one and a half
cheers for democracy I have the next
question I maybe I'm the only person to
ever tell you this but I read 1491 when
I was in labor with my first child you
are well I was finishing reading it and
it was so interesting that it kept my
interest up and it kept my mind off of
all the pain so so thank you well that's
the nicest thing that I'd ever said to
me so that's how that child is being
that way and it's a girl so that's why
it's so puzzling I wanted to know how
long it took you to write each of those
books doing all the research and how do
you set up all the interviews and things
before you go you said you went to China
nine times how do you find the people
that you talk to and I mean I know
that's a word prosaic question but it's
just I you know the books are so
detailed and fascinating and you managed
to compile a huge amount of really you
know interesting information plus
personal you know anecdotes and things
so I just wanted
went on that well I promise I did not
pay her to they know for me
they basically you just keep asking
questions and you know I don't have any
assistance I sort of do everything
myself which is probably stupid and I
kept going until the last trip I thought
you know I didn't really learn that much
this trip and so I felt like okay and at
that point also my wife and children
were ready to kill me so in answer to
how long this is actually unfortunate
anyone there's a couple sentences I
wrote in the early 80s so I could I was
thinking about one point claiming that
for my you know notebooks and stuff at
claiming oh it took me 20 years and
stuff but in fact I had what happened
was that in the ER in the early 80s I
was writing a story for for science
about the ozone layer and there was this
effort by NASA to go up and sample the
ozone layer various places along between
the northern and southern hemisphere and
they asked me if I wanted to write along
I was very excited of course it wouldn't
want that and so we landed in in Yucatan
and the equipment broke down for some
reason so the scientists and I rented
one of those old VW viens used to have
in Mexico and I went to the Maya ruins
and I was blown away
just you know I'd lived in Italy for a
couple years and he seemed to me you
know to my untrained eyes to be just as
sophisticated also huge I couldn't get
over how big they were and the idea that
you go to this place like Chichen Itza
and then you walk to the edge and then
there's obviously you know just huge
amounts of ruins just still going on and
on and on and I thought this is weird
you know when I grew up in Highlander in
your high school we learned a little bit
about Greece and Rome which I think we
should but I don't think the word Maya
was even mentioned and you know it's my
only hemisphere right it just seemed
weird and so on my own I went back and I
used the journalist privilege I would
call up I try to you know the
archaeologist and say can you tell me
about this
I'm from science and so I it happened
that by dumb luck that this was during
this period this incredible intellectual
feet where the archaeologists just
deciphered the Maya language which is
amazing usually when you decipher
written language there's a crib you know
there's like like the rosetta stone
there's another text that you can you
know match them up this was just done by
pure smarts it's a really an amazing
thing and so there was this enormous
intellectual excitement going on is this
because there's thousands and thousands
of written documents um and so they were
you know and so I wrote about that for
science and I gradually became aware
that other people in other parts of the
Americas are finding interesting stuff
too and at certain point I thought geez
some ways you're right book
actually this is for john tierney i just
wanted to make a comment and a request
of john to comment as a number of you
know but not all of you is that John
Tierney continues to hold the record for
the most hate mail ever sent to the New
York Times for his cover story some
dozen or more years ago in the New York
Times magazine called recycling is
garbage John back to Billie's question
about energy and what not why don't you
tell us briefly the story of your own
Simon Ehrlich type bet that that you
make well you know back in the 1980s I
heard about Julian Simon betting Paul
Ehrlich about things running out the
Paul Ehrlich had been writing these
things that we're running out of all
these resources were hitting the limits
to growth the end of affluence and the
amazing thing is that I just saw in the
science is it the current issue or the
next one that they're publishing another
article by air like saying you know but
can't afford to keep consuming stuff and
you know he and John Holdren John
Holdren Obama's science advisor joined
their look on this bet when they picked
five metals and said we're going to run
out of these and 10 years later just as
Julian Simon predicted they were all
cheaper than they'd been at the time of
the bet so that so Julian was kind of a
mentor of mine and then in I think 2005
the New York Times Magazine had a big
story called the Twilight it was it was
another Twilight in the desert but it
was a coming Saudi oil collapse and it
was a guy Matt Simmons who's an energy
yeah it was it was a he was a an energy
expert and he said the Saudis had
overestimated how much oil was there
that in fact correction was going to
collapse and I was going to cause a huge
problem in oil prices were going to
spike what a peak oil that that that was
gonna be there and so when he did it and
you know and I knew nothing about Saudi
oil production at all knew nothing about
fracking or
any of these things but I just what
Julian Simon's advice was always look at
long-term trends and and if someone
offers and if someone tells you that
resources are becoming scarce or more
expensive that's not what's been going
on for hundreds thousands of years
really resources get cheaper over time
so he said if someone wants to bet take
their money and so I bet him we and we
bet five thousand dollars and so in 2000
2005 to 2010 and he better oil was gonna
be I think $200 a barrel well I mean
yeah it was great publicity for his book
- I mean he was smart about that but he
genuinely believed it and I mean I had
offered him actually the bet that Julian
Simon had always recommended would he
and Eric you know they made a bet and
they said that the price Julian's that
the price of this will be lower in
inflation-adjusted terms in the future
than it is now and Julian I always said
that the really fair bet would be that
it will that it will take less labour to
buy something in the future you know
that the real that's the only thing that
gets more expensive in overtime is a
cost of human labor so that that goes up
over time the cost of resources goes
down and it's just such a strange thing
to see all this talk about
sustainability and the and you know the
and that we need to save all these
things when this stuff is not important
it's our time that is what is what's
valuable and so in the whole point of
recycling of garbage is why are we
spending all of our valuable time
sorting these materials that are
becoming worth less and less every year
and I and I find it a very anti-humanist
message to be teaching our kids that
your time is nothing but this garbage is
really important you know and you know
and I mean I was with a science class
where they spent in a science class
where they could be learning about
Newton and Darwin and they're out
picking up garbage and sorting it into
piles and it just struck me this very
bizarre
how much stuck here and so that's the
question is is do you do you maximize
entropy I mean we need more energy
that's clear to increase complexity but
but what when when does the entropy
become might there not be any it is an
energy the ultimate currency in the
universe and shouldn't we actually look
at energy consumption as the as the real
currency it's not gold it's not conch
shells it's what's really important is
energy consumption there's so much of it
that wouldn't we be susceptible to
serious inflation problems it seems like
I mean one rule that I've I that I
thought from studying the history of
ecology and in economics is that the
idea that you should even plan for more
than 50 years ahead seems to me I mean I
it's hard to think of anything in the
past where somebody 100 years ago could
have accurately could have made a good
plan to do anything I mean the only
thing I can think of as maybe somebody
who set aside a national park or
preserved and you know that if you think
in the future people will be richer and
therefore they'll value this more than
we do now for something else but it's
hard to think of anything that you know
that you would have done 100 years ago
that would make any sense I mean and
certainly energy policies the stuff from
the a that was done during the energy
crisis in the 80s most of it just turned
out to be completely you know awful
there was like
the Carter Administration one of the
things I was completely flabbergasted to
learn was that one of the Carter
administration's policies was to switch
electric power utilities from gas and
oil to coal and the same coal utilities
that you know are now causing you know
so much anguish are in fact deliberately
set into place by laws that were only
there were only sunset in 1996 could you
could could you talk up
you mentioned fracking a couple of times
could you talk more about the fracking
revolution there's now film at Tribeca
Film Festival the second in a series
talking about how fracking is going to
contaminate our groundwater could you
elaborate on those issues
well one of the things that was very
important when you talk about fracking
is its it's a new technology and there
are now dozens and dozens of operators
out there changing it and improving it
and so almost anything that you say
about the technology now will not hold
in five years so that that's that's
important to say for example you know
one of the objections to to fracking
said uses a lot of water and in some
places where there isn't very much water
it seems like an obvious worry at the
same time there's some numbers of people
who are working on methods of injecting
other things in there than water
including carbon dioxide so the so it's
a so almost all the environmental of
objections are to the technology as it's
in now and it's really and it's in
infancy and so I that's what that's a
giant caveat that I was a so the the
main objections to this are that uses a
lot of water um and I think that is
actually being being answered that it
contaminates water there's very
equivocal evidence on that I just and it
doesn't really make that much sense
because typically where you get the
natural gas from
and where utilities draw water from
there in very very different layers of
the earth so there may be some places
where they overlap but typically there
they're separated by you know a good
deal of of the earth and then the third
thing is I think this is actually the
most important is that there's nobody
who really inspects the pipeline system
and the wells to see if they leak
methane and methane has important
burning natural gas is important you
know climate change tides benefits and
they're negated if you leak too much
methane which is a very powerful
greenhouse gas and you typically if you
lose about 3% of the well that's a rule
of thumb
you've negate the climate benefits that
you supposedly want and I was
flabbergasted to learn how little
attention is paid to our natural gas
infrastructure system there's only been
one city that's been thoroughly inspect
its Boston then they simply drove white
panel vans down to 780 miles of Boston
roads sniffing for natural gas leaks and
they found almost 4,000 of them that's
just ridiculous it's dangerous and so I
the main thing I worried but I would
like to see on this regard people
driving around inspecting the pipelines
and so forth for leaks I mean you don't
want this flammable stuff just gushing
out